Now that we've seen a couple of different transformations, let's look at
several at once. Each of these equations represents some sort of transformation
of our original graph, f of x equals x squared 2. What I would like you to do
is match the letter next to each of these equations over here with the way that
it transforms this function. Then, if there's any missing information like the
number of units the graph has shifted by, please fill that in as well. One
thing to note is this last choice down here, reflected in the x axis. What this
means is that if we have our standard x,y axis here, we have some curve drawn
like this, maybe a sort of parabola. If it's reflected in the x axis, that
means it's been flipped across the X axis or flipped over the x axis, like
this. So, this graph below would be a reflection in the x axis of the one
above. Now it's up to figure out what equation makes that happen. Good luck.